Skoda has launched a Sportline version
of its flagship superb series this new
trim line boasts a new sporty look both
outside and in Marquart estimate as
kirat says you won't necessarily be much
faster than if you drive any other Skoda
Superb model but you'll certainly get a
sporty ER feel the sport line comes with
different seats and a slightly restyled
interior and exterior so overall it's
got a much more dynamic look more on
that later
however the superb sport line is by no
means slow are sluggish montes is the
sport line comes with a choice of drive
modes a fuel saving Eco mode an airy
comfort mode a normal setting and a
sport mode that shifts the suspension
engine and steering to a more athletic
setting either fit two different 2 liter
turbo diesel engines are available for
the superb sport line the more powerful
delivers 140 kilowatts allowing the
Skoda to accelerate from 0 to 100
kilometres an hour in under 8 seconds
and to reach a max speed of 233
kilometers an hour scooters designers
have given a superb sport line a
razor-sharp look you can recognise its
sporty credentials right away from its
black radiator grille frame black-winged
mirror housings and striking alloy
wheels the car also comes with a lowered
suspension and a black rear diffuser
with chrome elements
at four point 86 meters in length the
station wagon has ample space for
passengers and even more passengers the
station wagon as a cargo capacity of
between 660 and 1950 liters that's much
more than opals and Signia Sportster er
or VW s Passat variant can offer the
Skoda Superb Sport line comes with sport
seats featuring integrated headrests
Martha says Skoda is proud of their
simply clever design features that for
instance includes this pocket in the
door where you can store your safety
vest or this small lid contraption that
lets you attach a 20 by 30 centimeter
garbage bag but mater says that
attaching a garbage bag is really fiddly
you've got to be careful not to get your
finger caught in this contraption he
notes that there's actually very little
room for the garbage bag itself inside
the door pocket it's not exactly deep he
thinks if you put a garbage bag in there
you couldn't tell us much Martha's
tested one of the two diesel engines on
offer but three gasoline engines are
also available for the superb sport line
their output ranges between 110 and 206
kilowatts every model can also be fitted
with a direct shift gearbox and Germany
the superb sport line has a base price
of just over 36,000 euros admits there
are other cars of similar size as the
Skoda Superb
and an equally spacious interior they
might come with a few additional
features here and there but the superb
might not offer
and they might boast premium materials
but these cars are also much more
expensive
that's why Montes thinks the Skoda
Superb is a good choice for anyone who's
simply looking for a spacious station
wagon is their go-to valid in Germany
Mercedes e-class wagon for example
constant least 50,000 euros but offers
less trunk space than Skoda Superb Sport
line
[Music]